Beatbox is the original instrument.
It all comes from the voice.
Today, we're going teach you
the three basic sounds of beatbox,
which make up the foundation of it.
Now, the "kick"
is the kick drum on the bottom
and it makes the loud bass sound.
It sounds like this:
(Beatboxes bass sound)
Alright? You hear that?
How do you make that sound?
Well, the way you make that sound
is you take a "p" and you take a "b"
and you mesh those two together
and it's going to give you
what we refer to as the kick drum.
Pb! Pb! Pb!
So, alright, so you try this:
Pb!
Excellent!
Now, the next sound
is the almighty snare sound.
And the snare sound
is basically taking a "k" and an "a"
and putting those two sounds together.
And it sounds like this:
Ka! Ka! Ka!
Alright? So just try that, really easy.
Now, the last sound
is one of my favorite sounds.
It's the hi-hat.
The hi-hat's my favorite sound,
because it's always
on the tip of your tongue.
You basically take a "t" and an "s"
and twist those two together,
and it's going to sound like this:
Ts Ts, Ts, Ts.
It's great, right?
So, you put all those together
and you can make some really
amazing, wonderful music
that you can do anywhere.
We can make beats in the car, right?
So we can just drive
through the city, making a beat.
And it sounds a little
something like this.
Let's speak to them.
(Beatboxing)
(Beatboxing ends)
Alright, so that's how you can
actually speak to each other.
Now, those are really complex
beat patterns, right?
So, we'll do a few beat patterns with you
and you repeat after me so you can begin
to learn these sounds, alright?
So check this out:
(Beatboxing)
[Pb Ts Ka]
[Pa Ka]
(Beatboxing)
[Ts Ka Ts Ka Pb]
[Pb Ka Ka Pb Ts]
(Beatboxing)
[Ts Ts Ka Pb]
So we can take all of those
different rhythms and sounds,
and jam with each other
by listening to each other, right?
So right now we're just rolling around,
we're going to drop a phat beat,
maybe see if we can find some friends.
Check this out!
(Beatboxing)
[Beatsynth's mom]
[Pb Ts Ts Ts Ts Ts Ts]